today i will
present to you one of the most
interesting topics in my field of study
which is a graph theory
um i know the topics might sound a
little bit intimidating but what you
need to understand this presentation is
quite simple so um if you can do the
basic math like simple additions
or um simple modifications you are
pretty good to go
and also what you'll need is the
observation skills
and that's probably all you need to have
for understanding this presentation
um before i jump in um can i ask like if
any of you guys have been familiar with
this topic before
a little bit a little bit okay um yeah i
hope you get something out of today's
presentation i hope it'd be useful okay
uh okay about today's agenda uh first
i'll go over
some definitions uh to see what the
graph is
and next we are going to explore one of
the uh most interesting questions
in graph theory which is the shortest
path problems
and then we are going to see some
examples and we are going to
recap it at the end all right
and also feel free to interrupt me any
questions you may have just
don't be shy okay all right let's
dive in uh the question is uh what is a
graph
uh if you have been dealing with data
before you might have been familiar with
the concept of graph
uh on the left one you have the graph on
the x-axis
and y-axis and the right one you have a
bar graph to represent some data
and but uh this is not the graph we are
going to talk about today
what we are going to talk about is quite
a little bit different
and the definition of it is that graph
is a
collision of nodes and edges and
by nodes here i will use the red circle
to represent a node and the edges will
be it is just a straight line
so basically nodes can represent any
objects it can be
people it can be animals it can be just
just anything and the areas will
indicate some relationships between two
notes
and that might not sound clear but uh
let's take a look at some examples
here okay uh here i have a note that
represents
howard and i have a node that represents
mit
and they both can be connected by the
ish that says they are in the same city
of cambridge is it clear on this one
yes all right and uh
i can have the notes of matt and ecs
and both are the department at mit
i have akin this is me who is the
students at mit
and i study math and ecs
i can have a list who love math and bob
who hates math
and alison bob are rival
is it good okay uh
okay uh i would like to make some notes
here that this graph is
actually quite messy it has like so many
kind of notes you have
schools you have departments and you
also have people
and at the same time you also have so
many kind of edges you have the same
city
of department students and many more
so um in theory um this is not wrong
uh in one graph you can have so many
kind of notes and so many kind of edges
but in practice we usually refer to a
graph as
only having one kind of notes and one
kind of edges
and what it means by that if you take a
look at the right graph
you can see this graph has nodes that
are the states in new england
and the edges will is an indication if
two states
are neighbor
already still on the same page
yeah and this is uh
i also have some examples so you can
probably have a better understanding
uh the example i'm going to use is a new
representation
and probably you guys have seen
facebook before and what we are going to
do is
uh facebook actually have a very nice
way to present the network as a graph
and to do so he can have the node to
represent a user
and h2 represents a friendship between
any two users
for example this diagram here
you can see list here has
list has age that connects to emma shane
and allen
that means uh list has three friends
which is emma
shane is it
is it okay is it yeah
okay i just want to ask like to make
sure just everybody is on the same page
like um just a quick questions like uh
how many friends
does john have
four four yeah well they are
yeah there are four friends of john uh
bob uh
jill shane and leah
okay still good okay
okay i have another question for you uh
on the right i have a graph who's
whose notes are some states in the u.s
you can have many new hemisphere
massachusetts and many more
and the edges will represent that there
is a road that connects
two nodes together for example this age
is a road that connects main and new
hampshire this age is a road that
connects vermont and new york
so basically you can view this graph as
a map
and there are states then there are road
technique states together
yeah so um here's my question
you want to drive from maine to maryland
which is
the this circle to this circle
and to go to use a road you need to pay
one dollar for each road you take
yeah the question is that what is the
cheapest route you can
take
green figures
you can go along to the left edges left
edges
yeah uh new hampshire vermont new york
uh
pennsylvania and maryland yeah yeah
that's perfect
um there are actually two uh ships route
here
which are indicated by the green lines
and whatever route you takes you need to
pay five dollars
and uh this is what we call the shortest
path problem
i will uh explain it in in a minute
but um if you guys have any questions if
you don't understand the graph
you can ask me
okay uh let's move on so
um the shortest path problem uh
it is probably one of the most important
questions in graph theory
uh computer scientist has been dealing
with it for decades
and it also have so many applications in
real life
and the way we formulate the problem is
that we are given the graph
and we want to find the shortest path in
term of the number of edges
to go from one node to another like we
just did to go from
main to maryland and it's actually easy
to solve
by guys if the graph is so small they
need kita did it pronounce correctly yep
yeah he just solved it in like 10
seconds and it's pretty easy if the
graph is small
but uh the question is like if the graph
is large how do we do it
like on this one if you want to go from
the left note to the right note
it's probably impossible to solve it by
eyes because you know there are like 100
nodes and
thousand edges
so uh to solve these problems computer
scientists have come up with a very nice
and very simple procedure to find a
shortest path
and we call it the breadth first search
or bfs for short
and we are going to do it now and i'm
going to list the instructions on the
left
and we are going to solve it together on
the right
so to do it we are going to start with
uh
leveling the start node which is main
here with zero
and then we are going to see that from
main you can expand to
new hampshire so we are going to put
one at new hampshire and then from new
hampshire you can
only go to vermont and message sets
so we will put two here
and if you do the same thing from boom
one and messages it
you can only go to new york committee
card in rhode island and we'll put three
there
and we are going to do it again and
again until we find maryland
which is five is it clear
on the procedure yeah yeah
that's good okay so um we found maryland
it's
level five meaning that uh to go from
maine to maryland you need to take five
edges
uh however these procedures only tell
you
how like the number the least number of
edges you need to take
but it doesn't exactly tell you like
what path you should be taking
so the question is um how do you find
such a pack that
that cost you five dollars
and the answer is uh what we call
backtracking
and it is quite simple to so what it
means by by tracking is that uh
you have maryland f5 and you have minute
zero
you want to find a path that goes like
five four
three two one and zero
and to do that on the left one you can
go five
four three two one and zero
and on the right one you can go uh five
four
three two one and zero and these are
actually two pads that we
just solved earlier my eyes
is it clear for everybody yes
okay sounds good so um how do you guys
feel about
this example is it like uh too hard too
easy or just
okay sorry it's all right
all right everybody okay um if this is
uh not
too hard for you i have two questions
that might be a bit more challenging
for this one you still have a map
you have to have the same graph with the
nodes of the states
but now each road will cost you
differently
like for example from maine to new
hampshire it will cost you
one dollar and from new hampshire to
messenger sets it will cost you
two dollars so basically like the
numbers above the edge will tell you the
amount of money you need to pay
for using the row
you still want to go from maine to
maryland
but you still pick the same route i'll
tell you here that
um the old one will cost you 11 like one
two
three three and two
yeah can we do better
um i think in the lower part of the
graph we can
uh take the right route this time so it
would cost
four dollars yeah
yeah that's a good cash um you could go
this way you only need to pay for
all right how about the upper part
and you just find the charter way
the cheaper way
well we can go from new hampshire to
massachusetts to connecticut
to new york yeah yeah that's correct and
this is actually the cheapest path we
can find
so this uh type of question we call it
the
weighted shortest path problem it's
basically
the shortest path problem with some
variations
so here every age will have
the corresponding weight in this case
the weight is just the amount of toll we
need to pay
for using the road
it's already still good
okay so um as you can see the
traditional breakfast search will not
work on this graph because it will just
tell us to go on this way be of the old
way
but the actual shift route is just to go
on the green line
so the question is how can be solved by
using the
bfs
the answer is we need to do some
modifications
to use the vfs to solve it we can
uh add an intermediate node here so
we're basically going to split up the
roads
so from one road that costs you two
dollars it's going to be
split up into two rewards that cost you
one dollar
for each row
is the diagram clear for you yeah
yeah and also the same thing uh with the
road that cost you three dollars can be
split into three rows that cost you one
dollar each
and you can transform the graph from the
um graph with the weight
to the graph with intermediate nodes
as you can see message is set to rho
ellen two dollars will be split into two
roads and you can do the same for every
single age
and from here you can
use the bfs like we just did before
i'm gonna just show you how it goes
because it will take too long
you have zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine
and we can do the backtracking to find
the
actual shortest path
is it clear for everybody yep
yeah sounds good okay okay i would like
to end with some
a couple of examples that you may have
come across
so these are the actual examples in real
life of the
bfs so the first one is the cheapest
flight transit
if you have used some traveling engines
before like
you will want to go from one place to
another but
uh if you do the search it will tell you
what is the cheapest route what is the
transit
so in this photo you are given the
origin and destination and price
of several flights and for example here
you want to go to boston to los
angeles you can use the breakfast to see
that this is actually the cheapest route
you can find
and another example that i have here is
the
minimizing the signal delay so
if you want to call a friend like at
least one call about
when a hobby so the signal actually
going to bounce off
a lot of cell phone towers until you
reaching the
and from the signal to go from one tower
to another tower it
has some delays so we can
we can model this as a graph with the
node
to be the cellphone towers and the edge
to
represent the delays from toward the
tower
and we can use the refreshers to see
like what should be the
fast the route that signal actually
minimize the delay
yeah is the example clear to everybody
yep yeah and that's pretty much all i
have for today
um just want to recap everything up uh
today we learned what the graph is
and we see how to solve the shortest
path problems by the breadth first
search
both on the uh one without the weight
and the weighted one
and we also saw some applications in
real life like root planning
and minimizing delays
and yeah that's all i have for today if
you guys have any
questions i will be happy to answer it
i think everything is clear yeah it's
clear for me too
no questions from me it's good
that's uh yeah that's all i have for
today thank you thank you guys